hey youtubers is Charlie so Marvel and
Sony are down to like the last three
actors for the new spider-man they're
engaged in a slap fight to the death to
find out who's gonna be spider-man for
the next 7 years because remember it's
gonna be Civil War and then a standalone
Sony trilogy supposedly Marvel really
wants Charlie Plummer Sony really wants
Tom Holland and the other person The X
Factor is Matthew Lintz all very young
actors it gives you an idea for what
spider-man is gonna look like in these
films he'll be like a little kid just
starting high school the idea is is that
in civil war he'll be like a freshman in
high school then in the first Sony film
he'll be a sophomore then junior then
senior in the last film so you get the
idea even if it takes like 7 years for
them to make all these movies the actor
will still be in his mid 20s by the time
they get to the fourth film if they want
to read up that actors contract amongst
you know many other problems that was
always a problem before actors aging out
of the role Andrew Garfield is still
pretty young but you know this is part
of a big creative reboot so of course
they're gonna go with a new actor the
only Marvel film that we know
spider-man's gonna be in right now a
civil war but he could appear in
Avengers infinity war it's it's still a
long ways off the terms of the Marvel
Sony deals say that spider-man is part
of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
even though Sony still owns the
character so whenever they get to like
those standalone spider-man films
they'll take the lion's share of the
profits but Marvel does have creative
input on the casting and the stories
that they go with it's still very much
Sony spider-man but you know when you
see like a big board room full of people
arguing about what they want to do with
the character and the stories it's just
that you know Marvel has a seat at the
table now Brian Michael Bendis actually
told some funny stories about being
brought in to consult on the amazing
spider-man films he made it sound like
those films were made by a corporate
boardroom full of people who weren't
really familiar with the comic books the
good thing now is that Kevin Feige has a
seat at that table and he is mr. comic
book there's no other executive at his
level that has his familiarity with the
characters so if you don't have faith in
Sony have faith in Kevin Feige and
tangentially because that you know
people like Brian Michael Bendis Dan
Slott like really good spider-man
writers will also get a lot more input
that people will actually listen to
benda said that of all the input that he
gave to the Sony people about the
amazing spider-man the Andrew Garfield
version of the character the only thing
that made it into
movie were the mechanical web-shooters
it's like they took all of his ideas and
just kind of threw him in a waste bin
and it just went with mechanical
web-shooters
because the actors they're considering
are so young you might not be super
familiar with the stuff they've done
before
my initial favorite is Charlie plumber I
like him better in granite flats than I
like Tom Holland in Wolf Hall will
follows an amazing TV series and in both
actors are great so even if they go with
one over the other I don't think it's
gonna make a huge difference in terms of
the quality of the film I know even less
about Matthew Lintz he's kind of like
the x-factor he's done a lot of TV and
smaller movies but the stuff that he has
done doesn't really give you a sense for
what his spider-man might be like he's
in that Adam Sandler movie pixels but
that's not out for a couple more weeks
so be sure and go see that you get a
good idea of what Matthew Lintz might be
like and if you guys didn't know Charlie
Plummer is an American actor Tom Holland
is British I don't really think that's
gonna affect the spider-man character
that much I mean it's not gonna affect
the quality of the film it's just when
you look at Tobey Maguire you know
American spider-man Andrew Garfield
British spider-man I think the main
differences in their performances were
their own skills as an actor and even if
you aren't huge fans of the actors are
considering just remember they are super
young so Marvel and Sony will use them
like play-doh
they will mold them to get whatever
performance they need out of them
there's always been this ongoing Disney
joke about how they find talent like if
they don't find people on the street
they grow them genetically in vats now
that Marvel is part of Disney maybe
they'll start growing their own actors
and bats too all that aside though they
have to find an actor fast they started
shooting civil war in May and they shoot
for about six months so they'll finish
in October so if they're almost halfway
done with the movie it gives you an idea
for how important spider-man is to the
story meaning that spider-man probably
won't be as critical to the story as he
was in comic book Civil War but still
pretty big they wouldn't include him in
the film if he wasn't an important part
of the story and a lot of you were
asking earlier this year if maybe Black
Panther was gonna get that spider-man
arc from the comics he'll get something
like that and because Marvel owns 100%
of the character I mean yeah they're
probably gonna position him as much
bigger in the film but his story will be
a lot more politically charged because
Wakanda has all that vibranium vibranium
is like the oil of the Marvel Universe
like the most precious resource every
other first world nation is going to
want a piece of it and
including major corporations like Stark
Industries so if you want to make
real-world allegory what Conda is like
Iraq vibranium is oil so you have like
the Iraq war brewing the character Black
Panther though isn't gonna be an
impressionable teenager he's actually
one of the richest people on the planet
in the Marvel Universe
seriously vibranium way more valuable
than oil but even he isn't gonna get
like the Civil War spider-man arc
spider-man in the comics was already
friends with the Avengers so he was torn
between friends between Captain America
and Iron Man in the movies The Avengers
just learned that Wakanda was a place
they didn't even know it existed during
age of Ultron Bruce Banner could barely
pronounce it like that's how little they
knew about it so I don't think any of
them have even met Black Panther yet
although you know Tony Stark kind of
rides off into the sunset you know maybe
he tried to track him down like hmm
maybe I could do something with all this
vibranium the big question though is is
what's going on with spider-man in the
movie you know what's going on with the
character the good thing about that is
the Kevin Feige has said a few things
first off he's already web slinging
around New York City he's already got
his powers in like a loaf I homemade
version of his costume but he hasn't had
any like big mega fights so he's not
really on the radar in the way that
daredevil just landed on the public
radar at the end of daredevil season one
like there have been people writing
about the devil of Hell's Kitchen and
that hasn't happened for spider-man yet
too because he's already web slinging
around right now there's not going to be
a spider bite origin story to slow the
movie down there might be a brief
flashback but that's probably it it's
really a civil war that's gonna deal
with explaining the character so that
whenever the Sony films pick up they
won't have to spend the first 20 minutes
the movie doing an origin story I think
a lot of the legwork and explaining this
new spider-man to people who have never
seen a spider-man movie never read a
comic is gonna be done between his arc
in civil war in like extra marketing
material for Marvel and Sony so if they
do like flashbacks to his origin in the
first Sony spider-man film it'll be like
five or ten minutes tops everybody has
seen that Uncle Ben's story so many
times
onca number three Kevin Feige also said
that this version of the character will
be the most classically wisecracking
funny Peter Parker we've seen everybody
has their favorite version from the
comics but I think the biggest
spider-man
book writers right now that are gonna
have input in the film or the character
or Brian Michael Bendis and Dan Slott
Dan Slott actually just took over the
spider-man title again and just to be
clear the new version the Peter Parker
that just debuted in the comics he's not
gonna be like that in the film he's way
older there's a child he actually kills
venom like it's not gonna be like that
it's not gonna be that dark think like
classic Bendis ultimate spider-man a
high schooler who talks and acts like an
actual high schooler like I said these
Knicks for spider-man appearances are
probably gonna be like freshman year in
civil war then the standalone films
it'll be a sophomore junior senior year
if you're looking for a really good
wisecracking spider-man run you know
something that'll be close to what
you'll see in the movie I would just
read that original Bendis ultimate
spider-man just go all the way back to
the beginning of that that actually
reminds me I don't think I've done like
a like a top 5 spider-man stories video
so I'll probably try and do that in the
next couple weeks definitely before a
Comic Con so be sure to subscribe to get
that if there are any other like
spider-man specific videos you guys want
just let me know
Marvel isn't going to Comic Con I know
that's like a big thing but there will
be a lot of Marvel Comics stuff there
just to be clear - I think there's a
little confusion about this Marvel isn't
going to comic-con it has absolutely
nothing to do with what DC is doing it's
just that they don't need to promote Ant
Man and Captain America Civil War is too
far away so they're not gonna waste
money on a Hall H panel I just see a lot
of people on Twitter saying that Marvel
isn't going because they're afraid of DC
and that's absolutely ridiculous that
actually reminds me congratulations to
my Marvel giveaway winner this week mark
Specter you and a $20 Amazon gift card
just be sure to private message me on
the about page of my channel so I get
your contact info and because I didn't
have time to make a second DC video this
week I'll just I'll announce the winner
of my DC giveaway - congratulations -
tooth - squawk you also win an Amazon
gift card same deal just private message
me on the about page my channel if you
have absolutely no idea what I'm talking
about I'm doing a Marvel and DC giveaway
every single week this summer all you
have to do to enter those is be a
subscriber and leave a comment whenever
I post Marvel and DC videos super simple
it works just like my weekly Game of
Thrones giveaways which will also
continue all summer so lots of fun stuff
giving away tons of stuff this summer
real big reminder though Game of Thrones
finale this weekend be sure to watch it
is going down I'll be doing a
couple extra videos for it while you
wait for that you can click here to
learn all
about the rest of the cast in Captain
America Civil War and you can click here
to start getting ready for the game of
Thrones finale thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tomorrow
you